sh 310 baby Mr so City himself welcome
sir what's up man for people who don't
know you are a literal child you turn 18
in what December January so your
birthday's coming up yeah yeah but as of
right now you can't buy cigarettes you
can't uh you can't do much of anything
my son just turned 18 in October so you
know you really can't do much else when
you turn 18 except for like join the
Army or yeah join the Army buy some Mar
Bros or something right which you
wouldn't do right yeah uh you're still
in school though right oh yeah for sure
Monday to Friday like uh right regular
high school public school yeah regular
school what's that
like are you like [__] just late
you're the man at school I mean like if
people know the song like you know but
like nobody's like fanned out freshman
say freshman
[__] what is like a freshman thing to
say to you then then like oh my God no
like a oh some weird [__] it's just like
whatever you think bro like it'd be
weird like it's like it's like no you're
not real bro like what are you talking
about like get away from me freshman are
uh they're are kind of like a look down
upon like peasants at in a high school
setting right no I think I for me I
don't say peasants I mean it's more like
bro I just I understand you don't belong
here yeah it's like bro give I'll give
you a couple months to be over here I
think the high school starts sophomore
year and then the middle school is all
the way to freshman year in La like
where I'm at over here in Burbank oh
yeah no so I think like the Middle
School's 7th 8th nth and then the high
school starts sophomore year yeah I
started ninth High School yeah yeah so
you got ninth grade you got real like
little children running around over
there probably listening to uh lot of
yeet yeet yeah they love ye at your
school don't they I mean I wouldn't say
at my
school yeah freshman's like ye
I think all Gres like ye I don't like
eat you don't why I mean I don't dislike
them but I'm not like why you don't like
e cuz I'm a [__] grownup what do you
mean what do I look like listening to
Yeet as a 36y old man you know sometimes
things just they they come out and they
just go and I'm just like it's not for
me I understand I look I respect it I
ain't mad at ye seems like a nice kid
just not for me all look but then ain't
that the same as like somebody my age
not listening to like yeah a old artist
and like no you should know he's a
legend but it's like bro I'm 17 but I
wouldn't hold you to that I mean but you
know that's how it go like you be like
top three album all time you say
somebody that's like like if I'm like yo
if you heard nomatic and you're like nah
bro and then someone gets mad at you but
you know I mean albums have been
released and I'm supposed to just know
like that like like honestly on this
right here what you got I've maybe
listened to that Jay-Z one I can't name
a song though I know I've listened to it
just trying to explore you know what's
funny is that's the blueprint too
actually that's not even the first
blueprint which was the least I've
listened to it I've listened to almost
all Jay-Z albums but like they're
skimming through them like trying to
explore yeah just to kind of do research
yeah like like homework yeah in a way
and I just trying to see you know was
what was the do you keep listening to
the Jay-Z after though or you just say
ah I get it I heard it all right moving
on I have a couple Jay-Z songs that I do
like that are older right I don't know
what specific albums but like it's a
couple songs like college The College
Dropout that's actually album I like
that's a great album uh what about uh
like the Carter the first Little Wayne
album oh wait 2008 how old zero three
three okay it's probably songs on there
I like know like lollipop yeah I know
lollipop but I like right yeah like you
know that was Hot Snoop Dog doggy style
I probably know songs on there like what
was the biggest song on that album I
mean there's a lot dude it's doggy style
yeah so I yeah my age you know it's
probably top two three hip-hop album of
all time to an old man like myself yeah
fair fair sh yeah Snoop Dog Snoop Dog
has hit stuff like that I like know what
are your what's your upper echelon of
alltime great albums it changes every
day well what is it
today I feel
like I'll say like Lil Uzi Eternal will
take I'll
say uh L
yachi let's start here and you know
H uh
I would say to the Creator's last album
I forgot the exact name off call me when
you get lost call me when you get lost
the the deluxe was amazing too yeah for
sure that's my top three right now when
I was I somebody asked me this when I
was in Atlanta and it was a completely
different list but I'm saying right now
like cuz I was just listening to to the
Creator is the little is that little
yada ya m is that the one that sounds
like he's doing T and paa kind of yeah
like alternative trippy Rocky one that
came out yeah not a bad top three just
because of the courage no uh ever I mean
I guess we we could say that whatever
like just to get by but I'm just saying
right now what I'm like liking let's not
get by okay ever let's not just get by
come on this is the bootle cat podcast
this is Power
106 respect but it's wow you're crazy
bro anyway um yeah so so ever you got
yach's alternative rocket yeah because I
think you know I'm going to I'm going to
say it it's ever the reason why I say
that is I feel like that's in the age
pretty well and it was like you said
very experimental mhm his best album we
appreciate it when like he's no longer
here uh for you this song has gone so
crazy so viral it's obviously uh I saw
you originally had recorded it on your
iPhone which is crazy like the first
first early version right what is the
app on an iPhone you use is a garage
band band lab band lab band lab so what
is the m is you just do it into the
phone M you I mean you can if you have
like airpods but you can use your airpod
mics and then it records the vocals so
look if you have airpods you record at
the bottom at the phone if you have the
wires like apple wires you put them in
like that's what I did it's a mic on and
you hold it in front of like at what
point in time did you go back and
re-record it so it didn't sound like it
was recorded on a phone I never did they
just mix my vocals so the vocals we hear
right now are the OG iPhone vocals yeah
besides the clean version I re-recorded
the clean version but on my phone again
really so I didn't record so in the
studio at all that's so crazy wow no
excuses man no no I I think I didn't
start getting into the studio until like
now like yesterday yeah so you just have
the crib just save time so crazy I don't
have to wait on the engineer and like
send my vocals just send your vocals as
hey that's impressive man kudos to you
thanks um do you like uh well first of
all there's there's a few like what has
been the one VI cuz a lot of people have
made videos to your song yeah it seems
to be the it like dance that people are
doing
what has been the most surreal moment
you've had with this record where you've
seen
somebody post about it or dance to it or
acknowledge it obviously the remix is
[__] huge you got blue face and blue
bucks on it and mustard and all that but
in terms of just like people who have
like posted it like what has been a
surreal moment for you just coming from
being a 17y old kid CJ stoud CJ stoud
like when I saw him like hitting the
dance or like the squabble that's not my
dance but the squabble and then people
put my song behind it is like wow was
was this last week when he threw for 470
yards broke the this is like the first
couple weeks in balling oh no Rookie of
the Year Rookie of the Year for it
doesn't even I think to bet on it it's
like minus 500 if you bet like he's he's
murdering it you a football fan mhm mcky
of the Year me and TJ straw both rookie
of the years I you might be right there
uh I mean I gotta keep working but you
know what I'm saying 100% uh what's your
football team Rams mhm H what so how you
been a Rams fan for like three years
what's your team I'm an Arizona Cardinal
fan have you guys I don't think you guys
are well you guys went to the Super Bowl
and9 but listen well Larry Fitz yeah it
takes real it takes real intestinal
fortitude to be a fan of the Arizona
Cardinal Rams as well